هذا وقد وصفت الحكومه الالمانيه اقتحام
وزير الامن القوميه الاسرائيليه اثمار بن
غفير للمسجد الاقصى وصفته بالاستفزازي
واكدت رفضها لهذا السلوكي بشكل واضح واقل
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الالمانيه كريستوفر
برجر قال ان حكومته ترفض الخطوات الاحاديه
الجانب التي تعرض الوضع التاريخي الراهنه
في الحرم القدسي للخطر
الخطوات الاحاديه الجانب التي تعرض الوضع
التاريخي الراهنه في الحرم القدسي للخطر
وقد اوضحنا مرارا وتكرارا ان الزياره هي
استفزاز لذلك نرفض بوضوح هذا النهج ونتوقع
ان تلتزم الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده
بمواصله بممارسات الجيده حول الاماكن
المقدسه في القدس ووقف المزيد من
الاستفزازات المتعمده والسماح لجميع
المؤمنين والمهتمين بالوصول الى هذه
المنطقه وفي نفس الوقت ضماني تنفيذ
احتفالات المسلمين والصلاه في المسجد
الاقصى وحوله بطريقه كريمه
[موسيقى]